well it was short wasn't it but it was
sort of classic Putin it was it's
basically his storyline which he's he's
been peddling throughout the Swarm
before which is that this the West uh
the evil globalist Elites in the west
that are destroying Family Values doing
weird things that he can understand and
doesn't think Russians can understand
either with genders he's gone about in
the past but the evil um confusing West
is trying to destroy Russia um and uh
that Russia is being attacked by
russophobic uh Western Elites but also
he says trying to cancel the outcome of
the second world war and destabilize the
world order but fortunately a
multi-polar world is on the way so his
story is that Russia is continuing the
good work of the second world war and he
and his propagandists have been saying
for some time now that effectively the
second world war was Russia against the
rest was against the West they've even
said that the West created Nazis and
therefore it's kind of in the lines of
Russia's fought the West ever since
Napoleon and this is a continuation of
that struggle and it's a grotesque
perversion of and Distortion of history
but it's a line that he's peddling to
those who want to believe it in the
Russian State media many of whom do
believe it but it's very important to
say okay that actually hundreds of
thousands of Russians have left Russia
already because they don't believe the
storyline that that's being pushed their
way to justify this war we watched as
hundreds of thousands came across the
border into Georgia but also those that
remain many of them
um are not going out when I was there
last I was told many Russian men were
staying at home terrified that cameras
would be picking them up and sending
them off to be to be drafted so what
we're seeing here is is is a spectacle
it's theater it's it's trying to
reinforce particularly to Russians at
home
um Something to Believe In the storyline
The Narrative they can believe in cast
in a historic uh context but many
Russians watching this I think will
still whether they believe Russian State
TV or not will still be uneasy about
where it's going I'm wondering if this
is a sequel to The Great Patriotic War
the Ukraine war where is the victory
that was won back then